we're following the mystery of two
engaged doctors killed in their luxury
Boston penthouse Richard field and Lena
balanus were found Friday night the
suspect was arrested after a shootout
with police he's expected to be
arraigned today
Tony Tecopa is outside the apartment
building in South Boston
Tony good morning good morning South
Boston once had a reputation as a gritty
working-class Enclave more recently
luxury buildings like this would begun
to pop up and security is typically very
tight so police and neighbors want to
know how the killer picked his victims
and how he was able to get all the way
up to their penthouse before he was
killed dr. Richard field apparently
asked a friend called 911 from his
friend saying that there's a gunman in
the house Boston police say when they
arrived at the penthouse the suspect
began shooting the officers weren't hit
but they did return fire 30 year-old
bam-boom Teixeira was shot we have a guy
here who just killed two people and not
moved
investigators found a grisly scene the
hands of dr. field and his fiance dr.
Lena Bolanos had been bound their
throats slashed according to the Boston
Globe photos of the two doctors had been
cut up and police found a message of
retribution on the wall the victims
lived in one of the priciest buildings
in South Boston police think they likely
knew their killer a special access key
is needed for the private elevator to
the penthouse someone had come here go
up to the 11th floor to a penthouse we
got to believe that there was some type
of knowledge of each other here the
couple's Facebook pages are filled with
photos of their trips to Amsterdam New
Orleans Key West and other far-off
places dr. Milano's hospital described
her as an outstanding pediatric
anesthesiologist in the prime of both
her career and life her cousin says she
was someone everyone looked up to she
was on an outstanding woman she was
really happy dr. field specialized in
pain management his clinic said he was
noted for his tireless devotion to his
patients staff and colleagues
and the suspect had two prior
convictions for bank robbery and had
just been released from serving nine
months in prison he's about a mile away
at Tufts Medical Center where he's
recovering and he could be charged with
murder if he's not well enough for Court
Gail many questions there thank you very
much Tony